now you say that achieving good sleep  starts even before bedtime  enlighten me  so i always think about sleep is like an  odd it's not an on off switch it's more  like a dimmer switch so doing a wind  down routine ideally an hour but most of  us don't have an hour so start with five  minutes of relaxation whatever you find  is quieting just do it for five minutes  then move to ten minutes and really try  to set that stage and the other thing i  also would argue is that a good bedtime  comes with a good morning time so if  you're consistent with the morning  wake-up time every day you get bright  light you move you have a big glass of  water that actually helps to set your  bedtime so you fall asleep a little bit  better as well